hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
we're going to construct a hexagon as
follows
start with the parallelogram and then
join its mirror image as follows
let these two sides have a length of x
let this angle b have a measure of 30
degrees
now mark points p and q
such that bp is equal to bq is equal to
10.
the question is to solve for the cosine
of angle pbq
in terms of the variable x
this problem is adapted from the 2017
gcse exam and i had many people request
me to make a video on this problem going
back two years ago
i thank tom ben and james for suggesting
this problem
if you'd like to give it a try pause the
video right now when you're ready you
can keep watching to check your answer
or to learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so in order to solve this problem we're
going to need the following formula from
geometry
start with the triangle which has side
lengths a b and c
and angles a b and c where the angles
are capital letters this formula is
always true c squared is equal to a
squared plus b squared minus 2
multiplied by a times b times the cosine
of angle c
this is commonly called the law of
cosines
but in my research i found the following
interesting fact
in france the law of cosines is named
the theorem of alkashi as al-qashi was
the first to provide an explicit
statement of the law of cosines in a
form suitable for triangulation
i think it would be appropriate to call
this the theorem of al-qashi or
al-qashi's theorem and i'm going to try
and do that from now on
so this problem is all about al qashi's
theorem
let's get started
we're first going to solve for pq
squared
now to do that we'll translate this
length vertically so that we form a
triangle
now using the theorem of alkashi we get
pq squared is equal to x squared plus x
squared minus 2 multiplied by x times x
times the cosine of the angle in between
which is 30 degrees
we simplify this and then we factor this
so we have pq squared is equal to x
squared multiplied by the quantity 2
minus the square root of 3.
we're now going to get another
expression for pq squared
instead we're going to use this triangle
bpq
now focus on just this triangle and
recall that these lengths are 10.
now using alkashi's theorem we get that
pq squared is equal to 10 squared plus
10 squared minus 2 multiplied by 10
times 10 times the cosine of angle pbq
we then simplify this and we get pq
squared is equal to 200 minus 200 cosine
of pbq
so we now have two different expressions
for pq squared we're going to set them
equal to each other
we now subtract 200 from both sides and
then divide by negative 200 to solve
that the cosine of pvq is equal to 1
minus x squared multiplied by the
quantity 2 minus the square root of 3
all over 200 and that's our answer
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
[Music]
you